[موسيقى]
يتيح لنا العمل مع مزارع الأسهم
تقديم منتج مستدام
متاح على الرغم من مرور عام
وهو لذيذ
وطازج للغاية ،
لذا فهذه هي السلطة الخضراء في حديقتنا ، لذا فهي مزيج من
مزارع الأسهم مزيج أخضر حار من الأفوكادو
المدخن الساخن  سمك السلمون ثم مجموعة مختارة
من الخضروات التي يمكن أن تأخذ
مما هو في الموسم
[الموسيقى
] المنتجات التي نزرعها ، يمكننا حقًا
إبراز النكهات ، لذلك عندما
تفكر في الطيران على مساحة 30 ألف قدم مربع
، غالبًا ما يتضاءل حاسة التذوق والشم لديك
الطريقة
التي تنمو بها تستخدم مياه أقل بنسبة 95 في المائة ،
ولكن الأمر المثير حقًا هو أننا
قادرون على إبراز مذاق النكهة
والأهم من ذلك أنه يمكننا تقديم ذلك
باستمرار على مدار العام
[موسيقى]